machines are good at recognizing
patterns machines are good at doing
things and scale humans are good at
common sense we have creativity so I
think if we can understand what this
complementarity means and then build AI
that can use the power of AI to
complement what humans are good at and
support them in things that they want to
spend time on I think that is the
beautiful future I foresee from the
collaboration humans and machines you're
listening to the Microsoft Research
podcast a show that brings you closer to
the cutting edge of technology research
and the scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen using gap as the
reality of artificial intelligence
continues to capture our imagination and
critical AI systems enter our world at a
rapid pace dr. Ajay Kumar a senior
researcher in the adaptive systems and
interaction group at Microsoft Research
is working to help us understand a is
far-reaching implications both as we use
it and as we build it today dr. Kumar
talks about the complementarity between
humans and machines debunk some common
misperceptions about AI reveals how we
can overcome bias and blind spots by
putting humans in the AI loop and argues
convincingly that despite everything
machines can do and they can do a lot
humans are still the real deal that and
much more on this episode of the
Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
Ajay Kumar welcome thank you hey you're
in the adaptive systems and interaction
group at Microsoft Research what do you
do there I'm really passionate about AI
systems providing value for people for
the daily tasks and I'm very interested
in the complementarity between machine
intelligence and human intelligence and
what kind of value can be generated from
using both of them to make daily life
better we tried to build systems that
can interact with people that can work
with people and that can be beneficial
for people our group has a big human
component so we care about modeling the
human side and we also work on machine
learning decision-making algorithms that
can make decisions appropriately for the
domain they were designed for so we work
on dialogue systems work on
location-based services but at also the
core principles of how we do machine
learning and reasoning so what do you do
particularly my main area is the
intersection between humans and AI I'm
very interested in as I said AI being
useful for people because my PhD adviser
Barbara gross says this very eloquently
she says we already know how to
replicate human intelligence we have
babies so let's look for what can
augment human intelligence what can make
human intelligence better and that's
what my research focuses on I really
look forward to complementarity in
intelligences and building these
experience that can in the future
hopefully create superhuman experiences
so a lot of the work I do focuses on two
big parts one is how we can build AI
systems that can provide value for
humans in their daily tasks and making
them matter but also thinking about how
humans may complement AI systems one of
the biggest misconceptions may be about
AI is that it's more advanced than it
actually is I think there's been a lot
of conversation around that where are we
with AI really yeah I think when people
think about AI they actually think AI is
this thing that emerged in the last 10
years or so I think there are a lot of
misconceptions
Shabbat this hey I actually started in
1950s and there was the Northmen
conference on AI where the fathers of AI
came together than I actually met to
discuss what AI is define it and start
working on it and they were wrong too in
their perception of what AI is they
actually they wrote this dormant
document where they stated that if they
worked hard on this AI problem for a
summer they really believed we could
achieve AI very very quickly so this is
a problem artificial intelligence is a
problem we're seeing it feel very good
examples lights up your imagination it
increases their expectations and think
that okay if the machine can do this I
can imagine machine doing this harder
thing very quickly as well unfortunately
that's not how the eye works today
ai actually works all verticals we know
how to apply some specific techniques to
some tasks but unfortunately just being
able to do let's say perception doesn't
make it easier for us to do other
cognitive tasks and machines so that's a
big misconception we have to correct we
are actually very far from generalized
artificial intelligence our techniques
still are very specialized and applying
AI to every single domain requires a lot
of analysis deliberation and careful
engineering talk about the blind spot
problem mm-hmm in machine learning and
where does it come from how do we
prevent or mitigate it this is a problem
that we got very passionate about in the
last few years and the reason we are
very passionate about this problem is
because we are actually at a important
point in the history of AI where a lot
of critical AI systems are entering the
real world and starting to interact with
people so we are at this inflection
point where whatever AI does and the way
we build AI have consequences for the
society we live in right and when we
look at our AI practices it is actually
very data dependent these days so our
models are data hungry we give data
these models and the quality of the
performance we see from the models at
the end of the day depends on how well
that data is collected however data
collection is not a real science we have
our insights we have our assumptions and
we do data collection that way and that
data is not always the perfect
representation of the world
this creates blind spots when our data
is not the right representation of the
world and is not representing everything
we care about then our models cannot
learn about some of the important things
for example a face recognition system
that cannot recognize dark-skinned
people it's an example of the blind spot
problem our data may not have not
representation for these subpopulations
and then our systems do not work equally
well for all people yeah I think you
mentioned an example of a machine seeing
just pictures of white cats and black
dogs and then when it sees a black cat
it thinks it's a dog because that's all
it's been fed and told it's been fat how
do we deal with the problem of flawed
data or incomplete data and make it
better in the age of AI we have to
reinvent what our development pipelines
look like in software engineering
software engineering is a decade's old
field and with the hard way people have
learned what it means to troubleshoot
and debug this code that they are
developing we are at this point that
they have to have the same
responsibility for the AI systems we are
developing as well that's a problem that
my research focuses on in the last few
years we've been developing debugging
and troubleshooting technologies where
we can actually smartly inject human
insights to AI systems to understand
where AI systems fail where our blind
spots are or in integrated IR systems
how errors may propagate through a
system and we may not have any idea
where the errors are coming from and the
ideal ways of fixing them so the
approaches I work on really look into
combining algorithms with human
intelligence and think about how humans
may guide us in places where they are
not happy with the perform
safar system and show us clues about how
they can be improved I think one of the
other biggest misconceptions about a is
the machines don't make mistakes and and
they do you bring up this concept of
humans in the loop talk about that a
little bit more so for a lot of the
tasks that we are designing AI systems
humans can actually be guides for us
because a lot of the things like
computer vision speech recognition at
this point human are the real deal they
can do these tasks very well so that's
what we do in these systems when we talk
about human in the loop we think about
how to bring humans into training
execution and troubleshooting of these
systems as teachers what does that look
like because I'm envisioning research
and all data comes from humans I mean in
the sense that we feed it into the
machines when you want to bring people
into the process what does that look
like so humans are already part of the
process in AI so one thing I like to say
is AI is developed by people with people
for people and what I mean by that is a
yeah is not this magic that it just
emerges itself we have engineers
scientists working in AI systems putting
their insights into the design and
architecture of these systems when I
talk about development of AI with people
as I said a lot of the resources for AI
comes from people producing this data
and in this space actually the field of
crowdsourcing the field of human
computation has actually been like this
hidden gem for the developments we are
seeing in AI because what crowdsourcing
does through marketplaces like
Mechanical Turk
they provide scalable on-demand access
to human intelligence you can push these
tasks into the internet and people come
and do these tasks for you the same as
social media people produce all of this
data that AI assistants can learn about
and these web tools for accessing human
intelligence is very important for us
when we are building human in the loop
systems because now we think about
putting the human intelligence
through these micro tasks into the
execution of systems for troubleshooting
for training for execution so that we
can do these tasks better and when I
talk about building AI for people a lot
of the systems we care about are human
driven we want to be useful for human so
humans are actually very important also
in evaluating how the systems we build
are and that's another area where
crowdsourcing comes into play H a you
serve on a number of program committees
and study panels and one of them is AI
100 which is a hundred year study of
artificial intelligence and it has a
report titled artificial intelligence
and life in 2030 what are the big
takeaways of that for people who may not
read that dense I actually have in my
summary at the beginning of its I I know
I would I would actually encourage
everybody to read it so let me tell you
a little bit about what AI hundred is
and then I'll tell you our main insights
from the report AI hundred is a project
started at Stanford actually through
very generous contributions of Mary and
Eric Horvitz to study the impact of AI
on society and what makes AI hundred
really special is that it's a longer
titular study it's gonna continue 400
years or more because right now
everybody is excited about AI we can do
one study and forget about it in the
next five years it's not what this study
is about this study is gonna repeat
itself in every five years so what we
study it an AI hundred in 2016 with 17
other AI leaders is understanding the
consequences of III for daily ly there
was one big consensus we really didn't
see much evidence for either general
intelligence or the Machine achieving
some kind of consciousness in a way that
we should be worried about right now but
we also identified areas where we have
to be more careful about for example we
realize that we are not paying enough
attention to how we can build AI as team
members for people how we can build
raishin into the AI systems we have
today we also got very worried about the
real-world short-term impacts of current
AI practices on our society yeah so we
identified issues around biases fairness
explained ability reliability as real
issues we should be worried about
starting from today we could actually
see that these issues are coming into
play we were able to identify examples
that we were worried about so we
actually made a recommendation to
attract more research and
interdisciplinary attention to some of
the problems coming in the space what
other disciplines might be applicable or
important in this research it's actually
a very interdisciplinary problem it
touches law because huge hugely because
we are talking about responsibilities
we're talking about when something goes
wrong who is responsible for that we're
thinking about AI algorithms that can
bias their decisions based on race
gender age they can impact society and
there are a lot of areas like judicial
decision making that touches law and
also for every vertical we are building
these systems and I think we should be
working with the domain experts from
these verticals we need to talk to
educators we need to talk to doctors we
need to talk to people who understand
what that domain means and all the
special considerations we should be
careful about do you know that of any
effort to sort of link arms with other
developers and designers and companies
to have this sort of ethical approach
there is an exciting effort going on
right now called partnership on AI were
a lot of big companies who are
practicing AI including Microsoft came
together because they recognize our
responsibility in building reliable
trustworthy unbiased AI into the real
world of Kandhar people and these
companies are now together working on
best practices and other kind of Avernus
they can create to start addressing the
negative consequences that AI may have
in the real world I think this is a very
promising step we are gonna see what
comes out of it but I think it is good
to see that there's a consensus among
big AI companies to come together and
recognize that this is actually an
important time in our field to start
asking the hard questions yeah and you
would hope that people would be aware
that there's always unintended
consequences of any particular
technology so it's also that right now
the public perception is very important
and the current experiences we are
putting into the real world are
affecting public perception about AI
there is a important feedback loop we
have to think about so that the
experiences humans have from our AI is
actually a good one and it's gonna
promote more work in the space rather
than creating a cloud of fear you're
doing work here and you have out in sort
of the general public a lot of movies
and TV shows and books even sci-fi that
are painting a picture of AI and giving
people actual perceptions of what it can
do and how do we help educate about
where AI is and what it can do in the
real world it's an important question
how we can reach the public because you
know as a researcher I publish in
academic venues I talk to my colleagues
so we can have more discussions in our
specialized fields however the public
perception is very important this is why
when we were writing the 800 report one
of our target audiences was the public
so view wrote everything in a way that
any person can read and understand our
thoughts and that was very intentional
because academic people can get access
to a lot of thoughts on the space and
our main targets were the public the
regulators in this space and the press
so we really wanted to make sure that
our toss this is actually our thoughts
right this is not the field of AI but
these 18 people who spend a year working
on this problem
at least our thoughts after careful
considerations and deliberations would
be accessible to everybody who is
interested about this I think there are
also things we can do as we are building
our AI to make things more accessible
for people and also get their feedback
in so we know that our AI is not always
right so if you give ways for people to
tell us when they are not happy about
something and we can actually have
feedback loops to watch for feedback I
think that's a way we can kind of
incorporate more of the public thoughts
about the way we are building these
systems so where would you implement
that if you were going to get feedback
from the public it could be as simple as
like thumbs ups and towns down like I
didn't like what this system didn't work
for me I didn't like what you were doing
because if you get that kind of a
feedback we can have human eyes looking
at those cases and see what we are
getting wrong right now for a lot of the
systems we have there is no feedback
loop you are not really getting much
human feedback about what our systems
are doing we care about how we can get a
little bit more accuracy from our
existing datasets like how can we go
from like 98 percent to 98.5 how we can
do better
stochastic gradient descent and how we
can optimize all of the parameters we
are doing in the way we are students to
provide learning however we are spending
so little time into watching what these
systems do in practice in the real world
that's an area that my research focuses
on very much these days because I think
it's a very important problem watching
what our systems are doing with real
people in the field what are their blind
spots
what are the errors coming from and what
the performance in the world really
looks like because you the real world
may really not look like your existing
datasets in the lab so let's put our
focus a little bit more into the
real-world performance of making sure
that our stuff works in the real world
and I think for that we need a feedback
loop for the real world performance
[Music]
talk a little bit about this delicate
balance between self-governance and more
external locus of control governance how
do people manage to do the right thing
up front so that somebody doesn't have
to come around and make a law that says
you can't do that I think that is
something that the AI community is
realizing so that we see efforts like
partnership on AI is a community we are
coming together as saying let's get
things right before somebody forces a
stressor because we see regulations
coming from different countries all over
the world we saw some regulation coming
from Germany on autonomous vehicles we
see regulations coming from European
Union on data privacy and protection and
sometimes in some cases if the
regulators are not working hand in hand
with AI experts these rules may not be
the best things for the field even for
the real world performance I mentioned
issues around biases for example if we
are not collecting demographic data
about our users it becomes impossible
detect how we are impacting different
subpopulations and actually realize
whether we have biases in real world
platforms so I think it is very
important to have dialogue between
different people communities who have a
stake in this game regulators the press
the public domain experts to get them
talking with each other because if you
cannot explain where we are as a field
to the regulator's they are going to be
making some decisions that are going to
be actually impacting things in reverse
ways like the ones we see in biases and
we are trying to communicate I was
talking at the Aspen forum in the summer
about jobs in AI and trying to express
that no not all of our jobs are going
away some tasks may be automated but if
we are very far from automating a lot of
the jobs
humans make so just trying to express
what we think the opportunities and the
real challenges are in our field in
clear ways I think it's gonna be very
important as we go along I'm trying to
wrap my brain around how we do that I
mean getting an audience that's engaged
in this topic aside from being just
entertained by this topic that's gonna
take some thought and research itself I
think I think we have an opportunity
with this new interest in AI we have
eyes on us people are watching what
companies are doing in this field of
artificial intelligence we see articles
every week talking about how a is going
to be changing everything all the
sector's let's use this attention to
make sure that our practices of AI is
actually good and we are collaborating
with the people we need to collaborate
with to make sure that we actually have
good AI systems in the real world let's
turn this attention into an opportunity
that's what I would say I love that
so you're professionally and probably
personally interested in the societal
impacts of AI we've covered that
particularly as it affects what I want
to call the three DS disruption
displacement and distribution talk a
little bit about those problems it is
one of the things we study then they a I
hunt report as well and it's the number
one question I get when I talk to people
outside of AI like where are the jobs
going can you tell me how many millions
of jobs are gonna be lost in the United
States in the like next 10 20 years and
how many new jobs are gonna be coming we
are actually quite far from having
general artificial intelligence because
of that we really don't see this kind of
singularity like AI happening where AI
is gonna kind of teach itself to become
smarter and smarter and one day is gonna
be so smart that all the jobs are gonna
be going away at the same time we have
an opportunity to think about how to
prepare our society for some of the job
displacement that may happen
for example the
crowdsourcing marketplaces I was telling
you about like how we are using that to
train our AI that's actually a good way
to provide work to people who don't have
traditional work right now so that's an
economy unto itself there alone is micro
economy it's a micro economy and we have
actually done some experiments we have
research paper on it where we actually
show that we can have algorithms that
can sequence tasks in crowdsourcing
marketplaces so that by doing tasks
people actually learn how to do complex
tasks better so we can train people for
tasks without them even noticing that
they are getting better at tasks by just
doing them at Microsoft we have a
platform like LinkedIn that can actually
be a hub for providing work or for
training people or for making a very of
other opportunities they may not be
aware of so I have a feeling that if you
can think about how to prepare
generations for upcoming opportunities
and pair that up with platforms we have
today maybe that's an area if you have
to focus on really hard so that as some
automation is coming in we are actually
preparing the people for the changes
they may face not all jobs are gonna
going away because as a person who is
working in AI I just know how hard it is
to automate even the smallest of tasks
so we are gonna be seeing a transition
but I don't buy the statements that all
jobs are gonna be going away and not
only that we've seen this before and we
see new economies grow out of change
what things do you see that might paint
this picture of the human AI
collaboration that you talked about
earlier I think the key is understanding
the complementary strengths of people
and machines we know that machines are
good at automating repetitive tasks that
we have a lot of data for machines are
good at recognizing patterns machines
are good at doing things in scale but
there are a lot of things
machines are not good at humans are good
at common sense we can do counterfactual
reasoning we are not even close to what
this means for machine we can learn from
very few examples and generalize that to
things that they've never seen before we
have creativity so I think if we can
understand what this complementarity
means and then build AI that can use the
power of AI to complement what humans
are good at and support them in things
that they want to spend time on I think
that is the beautiful future I foresee
from the collaboration humans and
machines they are already seeing
examples of this there is this great
paper from it's called a greater work
between MIT and Harvard they can
actually have a machine do nearly as
well as human radiologists on diagnosing
breast cancer from images so that's a
story that we hear a lot but the story
we don't get to hear a lot is because
machines and humans make different kind
of mistakes than you actually put them
together the error rates you got is much
much lower from what the Machine and
humans can do alone they can actually
reduce human mistakes by 85 percent by
just pairing them up with people I think
those kind of stories about like how
humans and machines can think about
problems in different way and complement
them they are gonna be ways for us to
just as humans get better at what we are
doing today what should we be concerned
about or interested about in our ability
to impute human qualities to machines
form emotional connections to machines
yeah we've done experiments in my PhD
days and we were actually like showing
the same algorithm to people in one case
we were telling them it was a person in
the other case we were saying it was an
agent and the humans were treating them
very differently really ample yeah but
then cliff Nash has some work that shows
that even putting like a smiley face on
a an agent makes people to treat that
agent differently so perception is very
very important
you know in some cases it may actually
be beneficial to have an emotional
connection with a computer agent for
example show us Microsoft's agency
advice a lot of people in China connect
with your eyes and maybe it helps them
with their they do life and just to
connect with somebody because they may
not have you know somebody to talk to
every day so in some cases I think it's
really again application dependent in
some cases it may be beneficial to form
an emotional connection how did you end
up at Microsoft Research I'm actually
one of those that started as an intern
and got to be a full-time so I'm
originally from Turkey did my undergrad
in Turkey then came to Harvard for my
PhD and I think I was in my second year
and I was doing work on human computer
collaboration in particular about
attention management and how we can
build AI algorithms that can understand
the human state and actually know when
is the right time to ask a question or
interact with the person and I was
reading a lot of articles coming from
Microsoft research in particular from
Eric Orbitz and his team and I just
loved the way those articles were
written and the applications and the way
they were approaching those problems I
want to do an internship so I came here
for a first time as an intern in 2007
and I just loved it so much I came back
again in 2008 as an intern and then I
became a Microsoft Research Fellow and I
just loved the place so much the freedom
the ability to work on real-world
problems and the opportunity to impact
those were the things that really made
this place the best of both worlds for
me the fact that you could work on
real-world problems in scale but also be
in touch with academia publish share
your work you learn every day about new
problems so when I was graduating it was
a very easy decision to come here and
I've been here for the last seven plus
years it's hard to believe time goes so
fast but I've been in the same group
working with the same manager all of
this time hey Kumar
Thanks Thank You fun to learn more about
dr. Ajay Kumar's work and what Microsoft
is doing to make artificial intelligence
reliable unbiased and trustworthy visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]